We've got our last speaker here,
so I think we'll get started.
My name is Jason Somareddy. First, I'd really just like to say thanks to AACR,
for
highlighting this, what I think will be a fantastic session, I think is really
fundamental to
making discoveries and leveraging the therapies we have.
We're in ED53, Cancer Systems Biology, Ecology and Evolution.
So if you were looking for something on forestry or something,
you're in the wrong conference room, wrong conference center.
Format of this, we'll have three 20-minute talks and a little bit of time,
three to five minutes for questions in between.
And
then we plan to have a discussion, about 20 minutes or so,
at the end. So if you have a question that
you feel will
allow multiple speakers to engage on it, feel free to
hold it and we can cover it at the back end. Okay.
I'm going to launch right into it. So our first speaker is
Andrea Sottoriva. He's coming from Computational Biology
Research Center in Milan, and he'll be talking about measuring cancer
evolution with mathematical modeling. So thanks, Andrea.
All right. Thank you very much for the kind introduction.
Thank you very much for everybody to be here.
You guys are quite a lot for a field like cancer evolution.
This is Woodstock for a field like ours, so well
done. Okay. This is an educational session, so
I'm going to tell you a bit more about what we have been doing, basically the last
10 years, okay, of research
in the context of measuring cancer evolution, with the idea of first measuring and
then predicting it. Okay. And,
so this is, I hope, is going to be as interesting to you as it is
a sort of spiritual journey for me to think about.
All right.
So this is where I'm based now. I used to be in London for many years, and now
there is a new life science institute, which is called Human Technopole, where we
do a lot of different things, including computational biology, which is up here in
Italy. And the work I'm going to present today is done in close
collaboration with Trevor Graham, who's now at the ICR in London, and Giulio
Carvana, who was a postdoc in my lab and now is at the University of Trieste.
All right. For a very long time, pathologists and clinicians have known
that tumors change over time. They change phenotypically and
morphologically. So there is a difference in a localized tumor,
for example, in the skin in this case, and then something that starts becoming
ugly looking, invading the surrounding tissue, metastasizing, and finally becoming
resistant to treatment. But it is only relatively recently that,
thanks to genomics, we have been able to map that these phenotypic
morphological transformations are, in part,
linked to specific genetic mutations.
Some of them are genetic, some of them are not genetic.
But if you take, in this case, for example, the colon epithelium, you can
actually map that some of these transformations from normal epithelium to an early
lesion are done through a mutation that knocks down APC,
which is an important gene in
controlling Wnt signaling in the epithelium of the colon.
And then you have other mutations such as KRAS, SMARCA4, et cetera.
So there is, at least in part, genetic matching between the
transformation in the morphological level and the genetic level.
And therefore, it has become evident in the last 20 years that
this process behind this morphological and clinical
change over time that drives this cancer
progression is an evolutionary process.
So the same fundamental rules and laws that drive the
change in species also drive the change in
cancer. So cells mutate, and they get selected, and
they drive this change in population structure, and therefore,
they make a cancer metastasize or become treatment resistant.
So this is good news because we have a fundamental theory behind
this complicated process that we can use. Okay.
And the question that I try to tackle in my lab is, can we measure this process in
humans, and can we predict it? Okay.
Predicting evolution is an old question posed by Stephen Jay Gould, a famous
evolutionary biologist in the '70s.
If we roll back the tape of evolution, would we see the same organisms arising
again, like bipedal mammals? This is a philosophical question, so people say, "Ah,
no,
evolution is contingent to random processes like an asteroid." Some other people
said, "Well, there is a lot of convergence in evolution."
If you look at whales and fish, they converge to the same
physiological, biological structures like fins.
So actually, evolution is predictable, and I try to convince you that indeed it is
the case also in humans, where evolution did not happen only once, like in
life, in the evolution of species, but it happens multiple times in different
patients. There is recurrence. There is recurrence at the morphological level of
cells, if you ask a pathologist. And there is a recurrent level of genetics, okay,
with recurrent genetic mutations in driver genes.
All right.
So what do we want to measure? We have this complex diagram, okay, with all these
clonal expansions and changes in population structure.
You color the clones with different colors, et cetera.
But what we want to measure in order to predict evolution in the future is
things like positive selection. So identify what
clones are driven by some mutations or other heritable
alterations that change the probability of surviving offspring with respect
to the wild type.
So positive selection increases the frequency of a certain
mutant
in the population over time. We want to discard
mutations or at least model mutations that do not give you any change in
fitness. That's called neutral mutations.
So in the case of observing mutations, because with genomics, we pick a
lot of mutations, right? So we need to identify clones that
have differential survival with respect to wild type clones or clones
that drift around, okay? Because we need to model those in the data.
The data contain this information, and we need to understand where is
positive selection, where is neutrality, and where is negative selection, for
example. Of course, there are clones that do not survive, okay?
There are some lethal mutations in cancer.
Or for example, they are predated by the immune system.
So there is negative selection. So clean up by the immune system, certain
immunogenic clones.All right, that's the idea.
Now, the good news is that using evolutionary biology to understand
cancer is also very useful because there is 100 years of
maths behind.
People for 120 years have been studying evolutionary
biology in species with theoretical population genetics,
which is the field of mathematics that married Darwin and Mendel.
So the theory of heritability of Mendel with evolutionary biology by Darwin, which
knew nothing about heritability, and everything he said about heritability was
wrong. So there is great work by Wright, Fisher, Haldane
in designing mathematical models for evolutionary problems.
We can use this to study cancer evolution in the same way that we
use this to study molecular evolution in humans.
And they had the same questions. How does heritable variation spread in a
population? What changes to mutant alleles? Et cetera.
And some of the very first people that started using population genetics
in cancer to understand their evolution are two of my mentors,
Simon Tavare, who is my PhD supervisor, and Darrell Shibata at USC here in
California. Back then, they used things like autoradiographs, which
I have no idea what they are exactly, but you basically
look at the length of microsatellites in cells to basically
track their evolution in the same way that you look at tree
rings in a tree trunk to understand what happened in the past.
And they published papers back in the early 2000s, late '90s,
on how we can use genetics to track, with molecular evolution
approaches, colorectal cancer tumor histories, for example.
So this is great stuff because they were doing cancer evolution way before it was
cool.
All right. So
again, this is an educational session, so I'll give you an example of what you can
do with evolutionary biology approaches based on population genetics with
the most widely available data you can possibly find.
So not fancy stuff, okay?
Something like bulk genomic sequencing, where you take a tumor, you
cut a chunk off, you mesh it up, and you sequence the genome of the cells inside
many, many times. You get a long list of mutations, so differences between the
genetics of the tumor and the baseline
germline confirmation genome of the patient.
Forget about what the mutations are.
You look at the frequency of the mutations in this
sample. They are little. So you'll have that some regions of the
genomes have more coverage because maybe they have copy number alterations, and
some of them have mutations in different alleles, et cetera.
So what you can call is you can basically identify a variant allelic
frequency of any given mutation. So you get coverage and you're getting some normal
contamination, which is not mutated in the cancer because the cancer contains also
normal cells and fibroblasts and other cells.
Then you get the reads with the variant, then you take a ratio, and you calculate
an allelic frequency, which is very important for methods based on evolutionary
theory because we use this information, the distribution of allelic frequencies,
to measure a lot of things.
All right, this is a simple diagram where you have a normal cell here,
and at some point, the normal cell
acquires a certain driver mutation and expands, and another time.
It's a very simple diagram. Very naive.
But it already illustrates how you actually sample the data
from a structure like this. The tumor is very big. You don't sample all the tumor.
You take a biopsy or a piece of a resection, which is this gray thing over here.
And then what you do is you look at the distribution of variant allelic
frequencies of the mutations that you find here. So what will you expect to find?
If it's a diploid tumor, doesn't happen very often, but let's assume it is, then
a lot of mutations will be in one out of the two alleles.
And if this is a pure tumor population, you expect a lot of mutations at
50% allelic frequency. And you get a lot of
overlapping mutations from different clones because some of them are these
mutations in this stick over here, and some of them are these mutations after this
driver, and some of them are these mutations.
And then you also have some subclonal mutations, which I'll come back later to.
So you can identify clonal mutations.
At a lower frequency, you see subclonal mutations.
So you have some information about intratumor heterogeneity.
It's not like single cell, where you have really single cell
identified genetic information. Here it's mixed up. You have bulk.
But you have good statistics about intratumor heterogeneity because you pick a lot
of mutations and a lot of cells.
You have some confounding factors that many of you know.
Of course, if you have normal contamination, the frequency of the alleles, the
mutant alleles, are lower than you expect by chance.
So instead of finding at 50% this cluster of mutations, you find them a bit
lower. That's fine. In cancer, you have other confounding factors which are copy
number alterations.
Karyotypes in cancer can be altered.
So sometimes you have three copies of a chromosome, four copies of a chromosome,
one copy of a chromosome. So you get all these strange combinations of
mutations where if you have a lot of mutations in one chromosome, you double that
chromosome, then those mutations go higher in frequency, et cetera.
But the whole point is this. We study evolution in the
few methods that I'm going to discuss today using the frequency of the mutations
you observe. These confounding factors, they change the frequency of these
mutations. So you have to know that there are these confounding factors.
These lower mutations, the frequency of mutations, normal contamination, and copy
number alterations, they can lower or increase the frequency of this mutation.
So you need to account for those. All right, that's fine.
So okay, let's go back to the modeling.
We want to model intratumor heterogeneity at the subclonal level
with population genetics. So we can model random mutations.
These are Poisson processes or accumulation of mutations. It's all statistics.
We can do it. We can model genetic drift and non-random selection, arguably the
most complicated thing to do in cancer.
And this first part is about neutral dynamics, which is what we started with.
More than 10 years ago, we said, "Okay, let's start with really simple maths."
So
if you start from that simple assumption that basically there are a few
processes of random mutation,
genetic drift, and non-random selection, you can model the cancer as a
Luria-Delbrück experiment. The Luria-Delbrück experiment is the most important
experiment in evolutionary biology ever done.
It was worth a Nobel Prize, and it demonstrated for the first time
experimentally that bacteria infected with viruses
develop resistance to these viruses because of preexisting standing
variation, which is positively selected.
So in a Darwinian fashionOkay? And
these two people, they proved it with a very clever experiment,
where they seeded bacteria in different wells, and they look at the distribution
of the frequencies of the mutants. Okay?
And if all the mutants came from the same,
let's say, hierarchy or a phylogenetic descendant of the wells,
then the mutation is preexisting. Beautiful. Okay.
Won the Nobel Prize in 1969, and that spawned a
generation of models, mathematical models, to model exactly this
process because everybody recognized this is a fundamental process in
biology.
The questions were the same. There are resistant mutants that happen, how they are
selected, what is their frequency, et cetera.
So in the cancer, we have the same questions.
We start from a single cell,
okay, and we model it as a Luria-Delbruck experiment, where there is a sexual
replication, like in bacteria. There is no recombination.
There is an expanding population exponentially, okay, or other,
you can also model other sort of dynamics.
There are a lot of somatic events in cancer genomes.
Every time you divide a cell, most likely you have three, four, five, 10 or
more mutations. So every cell is different. That's totally fine.
Okay, and you have this single clonal expansion. So what happens?
You have a lot of branching with a lot of mutations, and you have more and more
mutations at lower and lower frequency. Okay.
And the solution to this problem, when you look at the subclonal mutations and you
ask the question, what is the size of expected given subclonal mutation
X?
It turns out that this thing, the size of a mutation, the
size of the mutant is proportional to the mutation rate divided by
the frequency squared. Okay. Why is this important?
Because the data are this. This is what the data measure. Okay.
The data measure frequencies. So we have now an expected
distribution of the frequencies in an expanding population.
So the model says, theory says, that you have all these driver mutations that
are down here in the trunk of the tree. They are at high frequency.
This is cancer cell fraction, if you wish, so forget about copy number.
Hundred percent of cells have all of these mutations.
And then you have more and more mutations at lower and lower frequencies, mutations
that are in the same frequency, but they are in different cells.
So that's the magic.
And you can transform the theory into data.
So you can sample the sequencing error in the data and simulate
data. So when I used to be in computational physics, that's what we do. Okay?
You have a theory, and you add noise in the measurement, the theory,
and you see if theory plus noise equal the data. Okay.
So that's what we have been done now more than 10 years ago with this paper.
If you really are interested in the maths, you can look at the proper stochastic
dynamics solution of Luria-Delbruck experiment, and turns out that is the
Landau distribution, which is
a distribution from physics, which you observe in other physical phenomenon.
It's really, really cool. It scales at one over F squared.
So that's the approximation. If you're really interested, you can look at these
really technical papers. But that's the idea.
So when we simulate an
expanding clone, okay, and we have a neutral one at the
top, so you have some cancer driver mutation, and this is a single clonal
expansion, okay, there is no additional functional heterogeneity.
What happens? Okay. Theory says that's what the distribution of the frequency
should be.
What happens instead if you have a subclonal driver event
that makes a new clone expand faster than the background?
Well, you will see that this subclonal driver mutation, which is this red dot
here, okay, is moved from a lower frequency here.
When this mutation happened here, it was not under selection, so it's down here
in the lower end of the frequency spectrum. You don't see it.
But selection increases the frequency of this mutation in the population, so it
moves this up here. And look, all of a sudden, you have a mutation at high
frequency moved here by selection.
And on top of it, you will carry all these hitchhiker mutations that were in this
lineage. They are unique to this lineage.
Some of them are unique to this lineage, but they are here.
So they only are increasing frequency. That's what you see. That's the theory.
You can add the noise in the sequencing, and you get fake data,
simulated data of a neutral expansion versus an expansion with a
subclonal cluster here, which identifies this
subclone with a positive selection. All right.
So for me, this was very important because coming from computational physics, you
want to have theory that generates synthetic data, and you want to see if you
can simulate the data with very high accuracy, then there is
some hint that you're doing things right.
Now, you realize very quickly, okay, that yes, you can fit these
distributions to the data, but you have to be careful in their interpretation
because besides the fact that there is purity problems, that there is copy number
problems, you also have a horrible sampling bias because all
these solutions, they are derived
assuming that you live in a well-mixed population, that cell is a soup,
okay, which works maybe for blood cancers.
But in space, when you sample things in space, you get really
funny distributions of frequencies.
And you may even undersample or oversample, mostly
undersample selection events. So if you have this simple clonal expansion
here, if you pick clones across boundaries, then you see this
subclonal cluster up here, okay, and this is the one over F square
distribution that you see in very low frequencies.
Sometimes you don't pick it here. You see you pick another sample, and it's in the
middle of this clone. You don't see, okay, these boundaries between
clones, so you don't see these events of selection. It's like hidden.
You see basically a single clonal expansion, which is what you observe inside the
sample. It depends what you pick, okay? So you have to be aware of that.
Now, I talked mostly about bulk sequencing,
which is very readily available. There's a lot of data out there.
But the whole point of theory is that it is not dependent on the
data that you use. The theory is about the biological
phenomenon.Then how you read these biological phenomena, that's another thing.
So the same concepts that work to understand
the frequency of mutations work in single-cell data.
This is simulated single-cell data, of course, otherwise this would be $2 million
worth of DNA sequencing in cells.
If you have a single clonal expansion, even if you label a whole group of cells
with another color, what you see is, and you measure the basically
frequency of these mutations in the cell population.
So for every mutation, you say how many cells have these mutations divided by
the total number of cells? Well, when you simulate data, the data look
exactly like bulk sequencing as they should, right?
So you have all these purple mutations, which are these clonal mutations, and this
tick over here, the truncal mutations, and then you have this one over F square
in tail of mutations from the Luria-Delbrück
model. If you have selection, you see that the population here has expanded,
okay? So there are a lot of cells with a recent common ancestor, and you see this
subclonal cluster popping up here.
Okay, so
if you use this theory, this works across any data types. Okay.
All right.
Where are we? This is, again, simulated data of what
happens as you move across the evolution of the tumor, and you
basically imagine sampling the tumor across its history, okay?
You always get this clonal class, then one over F tail, and then at some point you
see selection in action. There we go.
Selection brings new mutations higher into the frequency spectrum, to the
visible side of this frequency spectrum, until in this case, for example, they
sweep through the population and they become clonal again.
And what we have done is basically now extended the old school
method. In the old school, when you
try to match simulations to data, historically, you do it with a
statistical tool, which is called Bayesian inference, okay?
And it requires for you to simulate a lot, a lot, a lot of things.
Okay, so simulations. So you simulate the process millions and millions of times,
and you identify those combination of parameters that match the
data. But these are mixtures of distributions.
With machine learning, you can, with nonparametric clustering, for example,
identify the right mixture of distributions.
So you can construct the expected combination of
distributions, which are mostly binomials or beta binomials.
And these Pareto distributions, this Luria-Delbrück one over F square, and
therefore, I have methods that very quickly deconvolute the structure of
these populations.
So what can you do? Why am I telling you all of these things?
Because if you have theory, if you have a model, you can measure the
process, and these distributions contain information about the
evolutionary process. The one over F tail, for example, is
proportional to the mutation rate.
So you can, depending on the slope of this curve, you measure the mutation rate in
human cancers. So this contains the mutation rate.
This contains the size and selection coefficient of this clone, which you
can extract from these frequency distributions after you have done the feed.
With old school population genetics, there are formulas that extract selection
coefficients, et cetera.
That's what we have done. So you can take real
samples here, like leukemia and breast cancer, and you can reconstruct
their
evolutionary history, but also measure what the clones are doing.
So you see that some clones have certain mutation rates, certain selection
coefficients, et cetera. And you can use these parameters to play
the simulation further. You have the simulation
with the right parameters that you estimated from the data.
You can play the simulation into the future and determine whether these clones in
this leukemia sample, you don't see the histogram of the distribution.
Believe me, it's there. I didn't make it up.
You can play the model forward and sample here and see what's going to happen to
these clones. Is one going to die off? Is one going to take over another one?
So that's what we did. I think I've run out of time, but I'm going to wrap up with
three simple slides. The question is treatment.
Treatment is a very complicated
phenomenon.
You may have treatment that selects for preexisting mutations, like in the
Luria-Delbrück experiment. So you get these heritable
alterations that are selected in an expanding clone.
And here you have specific patterns of selection, which are quite manageable.
You may also have treatment that is driven by cell plasticity and random
lineages in your
cell population survive. So you don't see exactly clonal expansions, but
you see enrichment of some lineages.
So all of this is stuff you can simulate to really deconvolute this enormous
complexity and the sampling biases that there are.
So this is all, again, simulated data.
And you can see in the papers where we fit the models to large
datasets, and you can measure these parameters in dataset.
Finally, you can do the same with
spatially resolved
data in genomics. You can reconstruct phylogenetic trees.
You get a real tree here, and with simulations, you can reconstruct what's the best
tree that fit the data here, measure these parameters.
That is because the laws of biology that I told you before also determine the
spatial distribution of mutant cells.
So you can move from non-spatial models to spatial models, and again, fit them with
Bayesian inference. I will stop there because I'm out of time.
I hope this was informational for you.
I want to thank everybody in my lab and when I was in London and now
in Italy. And feel free to reach out if you are
interested in knowing more, and we have some positions opening.
In my
website, I discuss some of these fundamental questions.
What is negative selection by the immune system, stabilizing selection, the
predictability of evolution, how we use AI together with evolutionary
theory to move forward in our developing of models.
And
you'll hear more from Sandy, how we design evolutionary informed therapies, how we
use all this theory in the context of treatment design.
Thank you very much, and I'm happy to take any questions.
We have time for a couple questions from the audience.
You can use the microphones.
Andrea, I'll sort of start while people get
the time and bravery to stand up and do it.
Yeah, I want to go back to the
sort of treatment response and think
about what is the role of
gene regulatory phenotypic plasticity in sort of driving those
lineages or buying time sort of for those
mutations to occur. And I couldn't quite
understand sort of which of
those lineages were plasticity dependent and which ones were
not. Can you just sort of speak to that
and what the role of plasticity is there and how that's
giving time for mutation to arise?
Yeah. So of course, drug resistance is a mixture.
There is plasticity phenomenon, there are genetic mutations, there are non-genetic
mutations. What approaches like this allow you to do is to measure
if there is a change in population structure. Okay?
Now, if plasticity is very common in
cells, then you have a lot of surviving lineages, then you don't see a change in
population structure. It's not a measurable change.
But it's important to have theory because you can discard, okay,
Darwinian evolution in favor of plasticity.
You have a null model where you say, "Okay, I don't think there is population
restructuring here." So it has to be plasticity.
It has to be something that the cells have managed to
transform into without waiting for a genetic event.
If then this leads to an additional genetic event because these cells are sort of
drug tolerant, then you should see it again because you'll detect population
replacement.
Got it. So it's more based on the structure of the-
This measures-
... of the population.
Yeah, population structures.
Yeah.
Right. And then
you have to start measuring the phenotypic. The typical example is you don't see...
There are a lot of cases in, when we do experimental evolution in organoids,
patient-derived organoids, we see it quite a lot. Chemotherapy, for example.
You
see no population restructuring, but a complete different
phenotype. Okay? The cells are different.
Right.
They're resistant to the drug, but there is no population restructuring.
This, to us at least, plasticity, we don't detect clonal replacement.
All right. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah. Thank you for a great talk. So as you mentioned, it's really hard to
detect the subclonal mutation because of the low tumor
fraction or the copy number variation.
So what's your practical advice to detect the
subclonal mutation accurately in the bulk DNA sequencing
data?
Yeah. So when you
look subclonal, either you extract the different cells or you
microdissect heavily, okay? That's very expensive, okay?
And/or labor intensive. Single cell DNA
sequencing is still very difficult. Okay?
Very expensive. We do some of it, but it doesn't scale to
10,000 cells unless you have an enormous budget.
For bulk sequencing, there are UMI,
let's say, there are assays with UMI correction or
duplex sequencing. Again, you spend a lot of money in sequencing, but with
duplex sequencing and UMIs, you can error correct these
very low frequency variants, and that's where I think it's safe to go.
Then you start detecting very low frequency variants to a certain degree.
Thank you.
I have a question. Thank you very much for the wonderful
talk. This is already complex enough, but I
wonder too the sort of the physical
location of the
cells within a tumor
probably are contributing, for example, those that might be closer to a blood
vessel versus those that might be further away from a blood vessel,
other contributions to the diversity, and maybe
selection for some of the genetics
that are happening. What about metastasis as well?
So could you take into account
maybe multiple metastatic
lesions that are derived from a single
primary tumor?
Are you able to kind of piece that together as well with
your theory and modeling and collection of data?
Yeah. So of course, in theory, you can model whatever complexity that you
want. Okay? In reality, it's limited by the data that you can
sample. Now with the spatial transcriptomics, and I don't
mention spatial transcriptomics just because it's fashionable, okay?
With spatial omics
at the phenotypic level, if you believe that the phenotype is linked to the
transcriptome, you can get this readout of the
phenotype in a reasonable fashion.
We are very much behind spatial genomics.
If I ask you, give me the genome in space of tens of thousands of cells,
we're not there yet. But that's where you want to go if you want to model this
process in space, get the genetics in space, and at least
the transcriptomics in space. So
I think we need those type of data before modeling crazy scenarios that we can't
possibly measure.
Great. Thank you.
Hello.
Well, excuse this very beginner question.
For
passenger mutations, I was not able to understand
why its distribution is following
one over
F squared.
How this equation was derived here?
Yeah. Maybe we can take it offline unless we want to.
But yeah,
I'm happy to explain. In fact, this was derived originally,
if you look at... So we rederive in the context of cancer because we were
interested in doing it in cancer genomics.
But if you look at supplementary material from the
1990s, early 2000, population genetics, there are solutions to that.
It's a very old solution to a known statistical physics problem, in
fact.
And yeah, I'm happy to send you stuff.
Oh, okay. Well, thank you very much.
Yeah, we didn't surprise you with a whiteboard to derive equations
behind the ...
I don't think I... Yeah.
Being a PI for so long time, now I can send emails and review papers.
Right. Yeah.
But I don't know if I can go back to the whiteboard so easily.
Thank you.
Thanks, Andrea. Thank you. Thanks very much. Thanks.
I probably don't have to do anything because the AV folks will do it for us,
but Sandy's up next, Sandy Anderson from Moffitt
Cancer Center.
I'm really excited to hear about
this
circuitous route and back again. So thanks very much, Sandy.
Thanks.
Okay. Hello, everyone.
So I'm going to talk to you a little bit today about how mathematical modeling
is actually driving clinical trials and novel therapies.
We call them phase I trials because I is the imaginary number, and if
you're a mathematician, you should already know that.
And we believe that you should do phase I trials
long before you ever do real clinical trials.
And from board to bench and bedside and back
again is because this is really not a one-way street, it's actually a
circular process. So I run a department at Moffitt Cancer
Center. Our primary goal is to better understand, predict and
treat cancer.
We are largely theoreticians, and so we don't actually run
clinical trials, and we don't
do experiments in a strict sense, so we have to collaborate, and
everything we do is team science. So all of our projects are
MPI projects, multiple PI, and they tend to have a clinical arm,
experimental arm, and a theoretical arm, but they come together in a kind of
unified vision. I'm also trying to recruit for that department, so if
you're interested in it, come and talk to me.
So this little schematic helps, in some sense, crystallize that
idea of going from the board to the bedside and back again.
And often
novel drugs and novel therapies start in the preclinical
setting, and that could be in cell culture, it could be in animals, it could be in
organoid systems.
And often then you want to then move that to the
clinic. But often what we found is animal models don't
translate that well to the clinic, where we get really great
cures in these preclinical settings, but it doesn't
translate. And part of this issue there is that
preclinical models are designed to be homogeneous,
reproducible, and have small error bars, and patients, in
reality, are diverse with diverse histories and have no
care for error bars. And that's the reality is that with all that
diversity there, then we should be thinking about, in some
sense, channeling those therapies in a patient-specific way.
And of course, what we could learn there, we could take back to refining our
models, which could then be retested in preclinical systems and so
on. So I'm going to show you a specific example of
that. I think probably this audience already
knows about cancer evolution, but since it's educational, this session, I
thought it was worth just emphasizing that Darwin gave us a
recipe for evolution, and it basically required
variation and selection. And so evolution is obviously
completely accepted,
in the biological world, but is it in the cancer world?
I think it's still somewhat evolving.
So,
accepting that cancer is heterogeneous, obviously Andrea just showed us a really
nice sort of molecular view of that.
And of course, it isn't just about the genes and the mutations and the
clones, it's also about the context, and we heard that from one of the questions.
This is a slice of lung tissue that's been stained for immune cells, stromal cells,
and tumor cells. And you see this complex color of
web of interactions that's present.
And of course, within those tumor cells, then there's different clones and so on.
But I wanted to emphasize that heterogeneity isn't just at the
genetic scale. So we already have variation.
This is a patient with metastatic melanoma, and it's a
whole-body scan that shows the metabolic activity of their disease,
and it's been pseudocolored to show where it's high and low.
And so their brain and bladder should light up, but their torso should not light up
that way. And if you're actually to see the skin, it would be black with the
melanoma. And what you can see is that there's a
large amount of disease, but this patient has a mutation, the BRAF
V600E mutation, and we can treat it with the plexitron
drug and effectively eradicate the bulk of this disease
within a mere month. And so this is just a month later.
Their body looks more or less cured.
If you saw their skin, it would be pink.
They would feel healthy,
radically different. And you can see if you look closely there,
there's still some lesions here below the lungs that haven't
responded. And that's one of our big problems is because within
six months, that disease comes back,
and it's essentially resistant to this therapy now.
So what we did was we selected a resistant population.
And so
evolution, variation plus selection is playing out
in real time in cancer patients, and we're selecting for drug
resistance. So is there something different that we can do?
And so I just showed you this idea of essentially what we call
U-shaped response curves, which is where a patient will initially
respond to a treatment and then maybe even go
undetectable, but we keep treating them, and then they'll rebound
on that treatment and now be resistant to that disease.
And so this sort of continuous maximum-tolerated dose
strategy applies to almost all cancers and all therapies right now.
And so if we look at that cartoon there, the idea that the
pink population is somehow the resistant, if you select for that,
then there's nothing you can do with that particular drug.
So can we do something different?
Bob Gatenby, my colleague at Moffitt, came up with this idea of what he calls
adaptive therapy, and it's a very simple idea.
If you have that heterogeneous tumor population in a patient, instead of
trying to eradicate it all, you give a lower dose, you eradicate
some of it, and then you actually stop treatment.And when you stop treatment,
the tumor grows back. And now, of course, what you're hoping it's going to
grow back is the sensitive population to that treatment, not the
resistant. The resistant doesn't care whether treatment's on or off, it just
keeps growing.
And so then we can repeat that process many times.
We can switch the treatment on and off.
And crucially, that should be driven by the
patient's individualized dynamics.
And so you can see this sort of oscillatory dynamics of the
tumor burden up and down.
And so, one of the reasons we think this should work is because we believe that
resistance isn't free. Resistance should have a cost when compared to
the
transformed tumor cells that are not resistant. And here's two examples of that.
On the left, these are two breast cancer cell lines,
MCF7, and its doxorubicin-resistant counterpart.
And if I co-plate them in
non-drug media, the sensitive cells rapidly outcompete the
resistant counterpart. You can see the green over the red.
Comparison on the right, we have two pairs of metastatic melanoma
cell lines, the WM164 and its resistant counterpart to
that drug, that patient that just received the Plexxikon drug.
And you can see that the black line is showing that it grows
faster than the blue line, the resistant counterpart.
However, the 1205LU population appears to show
no difference in proliferative ability.
So clearly, resistance can't be guaranteed to always have a cost.
It may have a cost.
So one of the things that this adaptive therapy approach we're trying to do
is we're going to implement in the clinic.
But I wanted to show you a kind of really clear visual example of how adaptive
therapy works. So these are two identical simulations.
It's a little agent-based model where the tumor cells hidden here are
colored according to their resistance state.
So the black, dark cells are the most resistant, but there's a hardwired
trade-off, so those are actually the least proliferative.
The yellow and white cells are the most sensitive to the drug, but
they are the most proliferative. Okay?
And then there's a kind of linear gradient in between.
So on the left, I'm going to give continuous therapy, and on the right, I'm going
to give our adaptive therapy, and it's a very simple rule of thumb adaptive
therapy, where I'm going to treat the tumor until it shrinks by
25%, then stop the treatment until it returns to its original
size, and just keep repeating that.
And when I do that, what you see on the left-hand side, we get this classic
U-shaped response where we look like we're eradicating everything, but what we do
is we rapid select for those red resistant cells.
And on the right-hand side, you see this kind of pulsing of the
adaptive therapy population where you've got white cells
sort of shrinking and growing. But if you look closely there at that bottom corner,
you've got this sort of yellow clone that's slowly emerging and
eventually is going to fail. So that clearly showed the difference in
timescale that you could maybe control the disease for longer versus trying to
eradicate it.
So, this isn't just in theory, though.
We've done this in a number of clinical trials, and one of the kind of, in
some sense, most pioneering one was this in metastatic
castrate-resistant prostate cancer.
Without going into all the details, prostate cancer metastasizes to the
bone, and once they become castrate resistant, you've got a limited
set of options to give patients. And so this trial was
using the drug abiraterone, and because it was a very
expensive drug, and when combined with the Lupron, had quite
significant side effects, if we could give less drug to the
patient and control their disease for longer, because in
reality, we know they're going to fail that therapy after a
year. Right? So can we buy them more time, and can we give them less drug?
So this just shows one of the kind of useful things about
prostate cancer is that it has a blood biomarker called
PSA, prostate-specific antigen.
So you can take a blood sample and get a rough estimate of the
tumor burden that a patient has. And so here what we're doing is over
time, measuring the PSA, and we give one dose of
therapy of our drug here, and that shrinks the burden by more than
50% already. So we stop treatment on that next point, and it's
not until almost 150 days later where the tumor
burden returns to kind of... or goes actually past its original
level, and we restart that treatment again.
And so what you can see over the course of a year, we gave three doses of a therapy
as opposed to giving it continuously. Okay?
And then if we take another patient on that trial, then because we're using
this rule of thumb strategy of reduce your tumor to
50% of its size, stop the treatment, when it returns to
original burden, start the treatment again, each patient's treatment
schedule becomes very personalized to their tumor's
dynamics. And so their PSA takes a bit longer to
come down on that treatment, but then it takes even longer for it to come back up.
So if we actually look at the outcome of this trial, it's been published.
I will say we still actually have four patients who continue to cycle, and we're
almost eight years in on this trial.
But you can see here, compared to standard of care, the medium time to
progression's just over a year, 14 months.
We're at 33 months. We used less than 50% of
the drug. So that's a pretty significant
increase in survival. And each one of these lines is a patient, and if you
just look at black is when they're off treatment, and red is when they're on
treatment. And so you can see how different the individual patient's
dynamics can be.
And so,
one of the things we wanted to do was could we have developed
a virtual clinical trial or what we call a Phase I trial that could have
predicted the outcome of that trial and also
potentially optimized it? And so, way
back in 2012, one of my PhD students, Jacob Scott, wrote this piece
for "Lancet Oncology" called "Phase I Trialist." And
it was really more of a-A dream of what
should be done. It then took us almost three
years to actually turn that into an actual strategy, which
we implemented in metastatic melanoma.
And I'm going to talk a little bit about how we're using that today.
So one of the things that you realize when you're going to try and model
patients and their dynamics is how messy
and ugly the real data actually is.
And so in a clinical trial setting, you've got very specific timed measurements,
you've got very clean selected patients.
When you contrast that with standard of care, and so at Moffitt, we have
this MCAP database where we actually have access to over 23,000
patients with metastatic melanoma.
And so that sounds amazing, right? 23,000 patients.
But as soon as you start asking very specific things of that
data set, like I want to actually have longitudinal measures,
I want them to be on abiraterone, I want them to have the same
inclusion, exclusion criterias in the trial, all of a sudden you're
down to 100 patients. Okay? And one of the interesting thing
about this, and we split it to more or less two even groups, is that some of those
patients follow that classic U-shaped response.
These are patients who are being continuously treated, where, and you're not meant
to see details here, but you can see that all these lines have some sort of
dynamic. They respond and then they fail.
There's another group here who respond and then essentially flatline.
So they don't rebound, they just go flat.
So very different sort of dynamics.
So we wanted to try and include both of those.
And so we took this really simple model,
which essentially assumes the tumor consists of sensitive and resistant cells.
And it's naive, of course, to assume that we can actually
capture those dynamics with such a simple model.
But as you can see, we can actually capture those PSA dynamics
for both the U-shaped responses and these more leveled off responses.
But if I cycle through a bunch of those patients, you'll see some of those fits
aren't as clean as others.
But anyway, what this allows me to do is match the
parameter sets for those individual patients and effectively
create a cohort of digital twins, and
digital twins in the sense is that dynamically I can
reproduce their temporal sequence of responses to that
drug. And so this is on continuous therapy, so can I now
take that cohort of patients and treat them as if I'm going to
give them adaptive therapy and actually predict the outcome of that trial that
I just showed you the results for?
And so that's exactly what we did.
So we treat this
calibrated virtual cohort with continuous therapy, and of course, it's
a real control because we take the same patients now and I give them
adaptive therapy. Right? And what you can see on the right-hand side here
is the true trial, which is the solid line, the blue versus the
red, versus a number of different options.
But essentially what I'm trying to compare here is if I have the
U-shaped response patients only, or if I combine
that with those that level off. And you can see that there's not
much in it in terms of the
matching the real population dynamics.
But we actually could then have forecast that real trial
before it would even started if we'd had these methods back when we
first started that trial. And so the question is: Could we
actually have done better?
And so one of the things that we realized was we could look at the patient's
response to that first round of therapy, that
initial first treatment. We call it the first cycle
because what we do is we give them that initial treatment, and then
we wait for it to return to the original baseline
tumor burden. And depending on that timescale, bin
them into having a high threshold, a medium
threshold, or a low threshold. And what I mean by that is in the original trial, we
had a 50% threshold, which meant when their tumor burden fell by
50%, we stopped the treatment. So in this case, we now have a
25%, a 50%, and a 75%. And if we bin
them, then what we can see is we get this green line
instead for the outcome. So we could have done even better if we
designed this trial where we had just created three
arms to classify the patients based on their dynamics.
So we also have a number of other ongoing trials.
We're trying to use mathematical modeling to understand
if we can pull out insights. And so this is a castrate
sensitive trial. So what I told you before was castrate resistant.
This is a little bit more of a sophisticated trial in terms of it involves
multiple drugs, but essentially each one of these lines is a patient.
Black is when they're not on treatment, and then blue is when they have one
treatment, and sort of purple is when they have both.
And what you can see, there's a bunch of patients here who are still responding,
and there's some patients here who progressed early versus some patients who
progressed a little bit later. And if we just look at their dynamics,
and this is one individual patient's PSA over time, this is a good responder,
and this is one that progressed early, we can see that these
dynamics, could you tell that this was going to be coming at
some point? It was obvious before they started to fail, and
that's one of the questions we ask.
And so we looked at a whole bunch of sort of analysis of those patient
dynamics, and we actually found out something as simple as the
PSA over testosterone ratio
highlights those patients as being distinct even in
their very first cycle of therapy.
And if we look at contrasting these two patients that I just showed you, the
PSA over T ratio for the responder, the long-term
responder, is flat, whereas for this patient, 109, that failed
early, it jumps up massively and then comes back
down.So we're actually using that in the new
generation of that trial, and I'm showing you here some of the active
clinical trials that are using this approach.
Many of them are at Moffitt, but the bottom two are not.
In fact, this one here is all across the
UK. It's a multicenter ovarian
study with adaptive therapy, and this one involves groups in the
Netherlands and in Australia, and they're kind
of repeating what we did with our prostate trial.
But I actually want to talk to you a little bit about a trial that we're doing
right now, this work in progress, and it's this basal
cell carcinoma trial because it's
a really interesting use of mathematical modeling.
And I'm not going to go into the details of this disease except to
say basal cell carcinoma is a disease that can be measured with
a photograph on the surface of the skin.
And so what you can see here is
fairly gruesome images of lesions of patients and
this is actually a single patient
who had nine different lesions or maybe even more.
And one of the questions is, how should we quantify that?
So we built a pipeline that actually looked at rather than just like
the longest diameter, which is traditionally what's done, that looked
at what we call the color metric that tries to describe how
wounded or how healing that lesion actually is.
Because you might draw a margin on it, but it's actually a healing
lesion. And so you shouldn't count it as having a long
diameter.
And so this trial's in conjunction with Genentech, who's actually paying for it,
and they have a PK/PD arm, we have our adaptive arm, and
then we have a couple of control arms.
And so in our model--
Well, actually before I get to the model, let me just show you what a patient looks
like. So this is a patient who has seven lesions.
If you look at the longest axis dynamics, they all
look almost straight, like there's no impact of that drug.
Whereas if you compare it with our color metric dynamics, you can see
significant responses in all of these.
And blue here, by the way, is when they're on treatment, and white is when they're
off. If we look more detail at a lesion over time, you
can see it shrinking, changing color, and so on.
And so what we're trying to do is use
the individual patient's lesions to then
calibrate a mathematical model that will help us predict whether we
should treat the next time step or we should not treat
or stop treatment. And so it gets quite messy when you've got more
than one lesion. So if you've got nine lesions and seven of them are
responding and two of them aren't, how do you decide whether to
start or stop treatment? Right? And so that's what we had to do, is come
up with a strategy that best dealt with that.
And this shows the mathematical model.
It's a little bit more sophisticated than that one that I showed you earlier,
because now we actually have some drug kinetic
compartments. And one of the reasons for that is the drug that these
patients get, called vismodigib, is very toxic, but it
also sticks around after it's been given.
So it has a very long sort of persistent half-life.
And so you can see that some of the kind of lesion dynamics over time here,
and so what we do is we fit them, we predict what we should do.
And then this just shows sort of in real time what our current sort of
status is of our trial. We're Arm C, Genentech
is Arm D. And again, black is when they're
off treatment, and red is when they're on.
And so you can see quite different response
dynamics in terms of how much drug they're getting. Right?
So the modeling is definitely doing a job of switching that
treatment off much more frequently than they consider for the drug
dynamics.
So let me just conclude.
Hopefully, I convinced you with one very simple example
in terms of the prostate cancer trial.
There's an opportunity there for us to sort of predict the
potential future trial, both design and outcomes,
and potentially optimize it.
Hopefully, it's also an opportunity for us to connect with preclinical
results and map those to the clinic.
And then again, look back again and test some of those ideas because, of
course, we might get it wrong the first time around.
One of the things that's really critical for these models is a dynamic
measure of the patient's disease.
Not a single time point measure of the disease, but dynamic
measures. We need multiple time points.
And of course, ideally, we need spatial data too.
And if there's one thing you take away from this is really that patients should be
their own control. And what I mean by that is that we should look at how
patients respond to therapy and react to that
response, not just continue to treat regardless of their
response. Now, in practical terms, that's
quite difficult if you've got thousands of patients that are being treated.
How can you possibly tailor individual strategies to those patients?
And that's something that we're trying to do, is come up with tools
that could even be something like a wearable that could
drive or help you decide when you should take your tablets and when you
shouldn't. And of course, I've got to thank everyone that did
this work because it's a huge team.
And also the NCI for funding this work through the Cancer Systems Biology
Consortium. And if you want to see more about our work, you can go to that
website. And then if you're interested in mathematical oncology in general, we
have a community website, mathematicaloncology.org.
Lots of information from all the groups all over the world that are doing this type
of science. It's not just me, there's many,
and doing all sorts of cool and interesting things.
So check that website out. Thanks for listening.
Hi, Cindy. Great to see you, and great talk as always.
Thanks.
So,
my question for you is,
for cases where we actually have really good drugs that work in a subset of
patients. So I work on non-small cell lung cancer, and now we have four
generation tyrosine kinase inhibitors that really work
well and overcome even limitations from previous drug.
And we do see in the subset of patients, there are some curative
results. However, a majority of patients respond differently,
and resistance seems to be the major issue.
So when I think about this, I think, "Oh, maybe adaptive
therapy is the way to go."
But for patients that would have benefited by the
traditional treatment,
do you think that maybe adaptive therapy might essentially actually do them a
disfavor-
Yeah
... in that case?
Yeah, that's a great question. In some sense, which patients should we give
adaptive therapy, and which ones shouldn't we give adaptive therapy to?
And so we've been developing some biomarkers specifically to
answer that question, because when we look at the
range of patient responses, there is definitely some who
really, they gained nothing as a result of adaptive
therapy. However, of course, they got less drug.
So one could argue they still had a better quality of life.
But I think if you're contrasting that saying, could they have been cured
versus adaptive therapy didn't cure them? That's a different question.
Most of the disease settings that we've deployed adaptive therapy
so far are incurable metastatic disease.
I do think in patients where it's curable, we can still use
mathematical modeling and evolutionary approaches.
And it would be more about how you order and combine the
drugs to best facilitate that cure.
So I think in the setting like lung cancer, if you knew you had a
chance at cure, could you tailor the sequence and combination
of those drugs to facilitate that?
Thank you.
It's a fantastic talk. This is Mohammed Badamosi from the University of Florida.
So your neighbor, and maybe I have to come visit soon because this is fantastic
work that you're doing at Moffitt.
Thanks.
My question is in regards to chemotherapy and how
an adaptive treatment strategy may drive maybe a
tolerogenic sort of immune microenvironment if you have this
on-off, kind of creating a
chronic exposure to some of these inflammatory factors that
are generated in response to chemotherapy.
And I know in your previous question, you just said that this is more in
maybe an incurable metastatic setting-
Yeah
... so maybe that has some bearing on the question, but what are your thoughts in
regards to that?
Yeah, I think that there is a concern that, right, are you
actually selecting for something by starting and stopping
treatment? Because it is obviously a strong selection tool,
chemotherapy. And my sort of counter to
that would be, there actually could be significant immune
benefits to stopping therapy. So you might be
facilitating selection, but you could also be facilitating
or reawakening an immune response. Right?
So it's not as clean as you're actually selecting for something
worse. And I think, again, coming back to that idea, if there is actually a
cost to being resistant,
then hopefully what you're doing is not selecting ever
more resistant populations, but you're actually facilitating the growth of
more sensitive populations. But it is a genuine
issue, like over time, potentially new mutations could
occur, right? So it isn't just about tolerance or selection from something
that's there. You could create something new.
And so there's always going to be...
My gut is that evolution is going to find a way.
And so can we delay it? Can we slow it down?
Can we exploit what we understand and not ignore it?
That's really the kind of take-home message here.
Yeah, and I think alongside that, and perhaps we can talk more offline,
what are the ideas regarding using
other data points outside of tumor volume or tumor size or-
Yeah
... radiographic response? Because just like you said,
perhaps
looking at the immune arm, so T-cell abundance within a
tumor and stopping it once that reaches a certain threshold, those could
be factored into the mathematical model.
I'm not a mathematician, so I wouldn't know maybe the-
No, they can. That's a great point, and we're actually very interested in
context, and I think that the environment here, we strongly believe
cost is context-dependent. So it matters
where you are, and somebody asked Andrea a question about close to a blood
vessel or further away. That's an important contextual
difference, both in terms of drug and nutrient availability.
But other players, stroma, immune cells,
other structural support elements could directly impact whether you'll
respond to a drug independent of being resistant through some
mutational means. So I think those are important aspects that
need to be considered.
Excellent. Thank you so much.
Thank you, Dr Anderson. Excellent speech.
I came from NCI, and I was involved in
cancer immunotherapy.
Here, since you are developing a mathematical model
for a specific treatment, start and go, stop and-
Yeah
... just manipulate the UCARB and reduce the
resistance.
I'm wondering if you have tried or noticed any
studies
that used different type of treatment.
One is chemo, in your case here, and then cell
therapy
in between, so that they can prolong the
CARB a little better, because both treatment has a different
dynamics.
Yeah.
One is live cell, one is
Small molecules.
Yeah. I think, again, another great question.
So I didn't talk about it, but our metastatic melanoma trial uses
a kind of immune checkpoint inhibitor as a backbone therapy, and then we have
intermittent targeted therapy with our adaptive arm.
And of course, that's a more complex interaction because
the immunotherapy is evolving or causing some sort of
evolutionary selection there as we then apply our targeted
therapies. But one of the things is if you try to give those three
drugs, the two targeted therapies and the immunotherapy simultaneously,
that's a lot for a patient to take, right?
And by giving the backbone of the immunotherapy and then putting the
pressure on and off of those targeted therapies, we could actually give
those patients that triplet occasionally, and they
responded just as well, if not better, than the
triplet together. But that was more of a toxicity feature.
But I think your point here of there's other
tools that one can use is an important one, and
we have a whole multi-drug adaptive therapy piece of research that we're
doing, which is one could imagine that if I'm treating
intermittently with one drug, could I actually deploy another in the
off periods that exploits the mechanism
of resistance to the first drug? So you'd actually switch
between those two potentially. So there's all sorts
of strategies, and that's one of the beautiful things about modeling that you can
sort of come up with and simulate and test out, find the best
strategies, and then, of course, hopefully test them in pre-clinical systems and in
the clinic.
Thank you.
Hi. Thank you. Great talk. My name's Chris Boniface.
I'm a post-doc in Jamie Lindell's lab at Cambridge, and I just want to give
a shameless plug. This is a really great newsletter.
I would highly recommend it, partly because my paper with Jamie will
be the artwork for- ... I think two weeks from now's issue.
So I would invite everybody to go check that out.
My question to you is, it looks like you've used PSA and
lesion size and these other clinical measurements.
I'm wondering, this seems like a perfect opportunity to use circulating tumor DNA,
and I'm assuming there's lots of pitfalls
there. I'm just wondering if you have any experience in this context with that as a
biomarker for tumor burden.
Yes, great question, and thanks for your contribution to the community.
I appreciate it.
In the melanoma trial that's not published, it's still actively going,
we're using ctDNA there, and we're looking at the BRAF mutant companies in
the ctDNA because there isn't a good blood biomarker
for melanoma. But we're also using clinical imaging and
we're using LDH levels. We're using anything we can measure on those
patients to try and look at those dynamics.
The problem is that ctDNA is a crude tool
right now. It's very kind of blunt in its
ability to see stuff, right? It depends
on some patients shed a lot more than others, and it's not
consistent. However, there is a kind of dream goal,
I think, with ctDNA, where could we actually see clonal
dynamics in a patient over time, right?
If we can get to that resolution, and of course, probably in the future,
we will be able to do that with sufficient technologies, and
then one could imagine that that could directly motivate
what the next therapy should be and when you should start and stop because you
actually see the clone emerging that's going to now take
over as the next dominant player in that next cycle.
So agreed.
That's right. Thank you.
Thanks.
I guess I should probably introduce our
Oh, you're going to do it. Thanks.
Our chair here and organizer of this session,
who's... I don't know how we get it to come up, though.
I don't know how we get it to come up either.
Here we go.
They're going to do it over there.
They'll do it, yeah.
Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah. So Jason Somareddi is someone
who's really been instrumental in sort of the cancer evolution space
and of course, thinking about ecology.
So it's great to have him here and bringing this sort of group together, and
I'm really looking forward to hearing about his work in targeting
drug-induced quiescence. Jason, thanks.
Thanks.
Yeah. Thanks so much. Really appreciate you guys being
here and doing this with me. So I know we're in a closed
room with no windows,
but I'm going to encourage you, I'm going to try my best.
In San Diego, we're in a closed room with no windows in San Diego.
So I'm going to try my best to sort of take you out of that from time to time.
So we'll go to a trip to the forest and maybe to
Madagascar and some other places, at least virtually.
If you want to close your eyes and follow along with me, please do.
But I'm glad that Sandy talked about prostate cancer a little bit, so it
takes some of the burden off of me here.
But I'm going to take a different tack from our
other two speakers and sort of focus on a disease state and
a time in the treatment progression, and that
is the response, so the therapeutic response.
And the reason we sort of asked Andrea about plasticity is because
we're thinking a lot about that. So this is like
a quintessential treatment journey for
prostate cancer. So tumor growth is on the Y,
and
some metric of time is on the X, right?
And local disease is treated with surgery and
radiation after some clinical detection and diagnosis.
That eradicates a lot of the population of the cancer cell
population.
And
upon metastatic progression, really, there's a
combination of things that target the androgen receptor, so
ADT and ARPIsAnd eventually
this continues to progress, as you've sort of seen with what Sandy's talked
about, in which there's a therapy-resistant state.
And at that point, there's very
little that can be done for patients.
The treatment windows and the response windows get smaller and
smaller. And there are life-prolonging
therapies, but, again, those times are much smaller in
terms of the response. And
underlying this dynamic is
probably the same cartoon that
one of the other speakers had, which is there's a
genetically and non-genetically diverse population
of cancer cells that undergo a bottleneck,
right, in the response. And if you let that go
long enough and just keep giving the same drug, that
population has time to respond to the drug,
evolve, and readapt and rediversify.
And so we feel like this area of response is a really
important window of opportunity to think about.
And this is borne out in the clinical data where you see that these
therapies, all different
AR pathway inhibitors of some form or another.
There's great
improvement in overall survival or progression-free survival, but there's an
inevitable emergence of resistance.
And here's our first trip
to elsewhere from the room. But, we really think
about these populations of cancer cells from
the point of view of any organism, any system in
an ecological environment.
I should have replaced this with, I don't know, a lizard or something for San
Diego. But, in North Carolina, we have a lot of squirrels.
So if you just think of cancer cells as a squirrel for our
analogy, right? A population of squirrels.
Those cells are really subject, that population is really
subject to the ecology of the body, right?
So there's only so many things that a squirrel can do
in the forest, right? It has to compete.
We heard about some of that competition.
It has to compete for space and resources.
It can
model its niche, and we heard earlier this morning about
the pre-metastatic niche. And really, cancer cells are like the
beavers of the body because they're just remodeling the niche even
before they arrive at a metastatic site.
The resource depletion is really tied to
migratory pathways, and these are evolutionarily conserved
migratory pathways. So, for example, hypoxia.
HIF1 is linked to twist, a
pro-migratory protein. That's
conserved from all the way through eukaryotes.
There's also clearly predator-prey interactions, and cancer cells do
a great job of altering those interactions.
They become commensal interactions, so they shut off that
predator-prey dynamic. And then, of course, there's
tremendous geographic variation in supply of blood, waste
products, and physical barriers.
But therapy really cuts down the forest.
Therapy really remodels the whole ecosystem, right?
It causes widespread death of the cancer cell population often,
but it also alters the ecology. And so we really wanted to think about
this process.
And so we've turned to sort of what
other animals and plants and organisms do
under resource constraint. And why am I showing you a date
palm? Well, this is Methuselah. This is a
2,000-year-old date palm, and you must be a pretty
badass plant if you have a biblical name like this.
So Methuselah was germinated after
2,000 years of dormancy, right? So,
the same thing happens in the dry season in
Madagascar.
You see tremendous resource deprivation in terms of
vegetation and precipitation in the dry season, and then
this reemergence of rain and
vegetation. And fat-tailed dwarf lemurs
undergo these extended periods of hibernation during these
times in which they can lower their heart rate and their breath rate
substantially,
utilizing the fat that they store in their tails.
And if I
happened to be at AACR in a closed room with no windows,
and I pointed this out to you, you would clearly tell me that this is a cancer
signaling network, right? There's MEK and PTEN and insulin receptor, all the
things that we're hearing about, and we know about and love.
But this is the signaling pathway, the proteomics of a hibernating
bear. And so the
resource constraint, the networks that are embedded
within animals, plants, organisms that
respond to resource constraint are evolutionarily
conserved throughout the tree of life.
And cancer cells are, I would argue, the same.
So we have this hypothesis
that this response period
of therapy, of ARPs, really is
like a hibernating bear, a hibernating lemur,
a dormant date palm. And so we really
wanted to model this process, and we did a very simple series of
molecular biology experiments that I think turned up a really
fascinating observation. This is all work done by Subhrajit
Debnath, a postdoc in my-He took a cell line in
vitro and exposed it to repeated chronic
doses of enzalutamide, an AR pathway inhibitor,
for about a year.
And then he repeated this experiment.
And I won't go into sort of all the details of
how he did that in different ways, but he essentially
repeated his experiment three times in three different sets of
cells.
And what we were surprised by was that, and Sandy alluded
to this actually, that
there's a cost to resistance, but it's not the cost we thought.
So
the cost that doesn't seem to exist is there's not a growth
cost. So
whether these are enzalutamide drug sensitive or drug resistant cells,
they're still inhibited by the drug. Their growth is still inhibited.
The cost
and the difference in fitness really comes in
the apoptosis inhibition. So really, these cells are
more resistant, but they're more resistant by resisting
apoptosis. They're not
at a fitness advantage
in their growth. They're at a fitness advantage in their
ability to avoid death.
And that should have been a clue,
but embarrassingly wasn't for a really long time,
and I've sort of reversed
history or backfilled history to make it seem like that was a clue.
But it absolutely was a clue very much later than it should have
been.
For any of the prostate cancer aficionados here,
these cells are,
they maintain-- So sensitive is S and resistant is R.
They maintain androgen receptor.
They don't seem to increase this
mechanism of resistance, ARV7 too much.
And they really vary widely in their genomic
features. Importantly, they don't undergo this cellular
plasticity that
would turn them more neuroendocrine like.
So they're not
becoming a totally different type of
cancer, or subtype of cancer.
And really, they display what we would argue is a convergent
evolutionary signaling.
If you look at array CGH and
whole exome sequencing and RNA seq in bulk, you don't
see very many shared changes whatsoever.
In fact, we can't pick out any shared DNA level changes.
There are some changes, but they're all different among these different cell
lines. And remember, they're all the same cell line, but
they're arriving at shared
phospho-protein
changes, alterations. So there's a substantial increase in
their shared phospho-protein events.
And what that shared phospho-protein signaling event is,
is really stress, a stress signal.
So all of these models have upregulation of p38,
a classic cellular stress response gene.
They also have upregulation, again, sensitive is S,
resistant or persistent is R,
they have upregulation in all of these stress response
proteins, phospho-proteins and proteins.
At least two out of three models activate p21,
a well-known connection to cell
growth arrest with p38. And then in clinical
specimens,
we see an increase in phospho-p38 in metastatic
disease compared to primary tumor,
broadly metastatic disease, so
from various sites, and under various treatment regimens,
but most ADT and ARPI. And then,
in a separate cohort of metastatic castration-resistant
prostate cancer, all but one of the patients have
enrichment for phospho p38
targets.
And we think that this
pathway p30 is really critical for the growth of
the
resistant
tumors in the presence of enzalutamide because we can give an
inhibitor, a small molecule inhibitor to p38, and we essentially
flatline the growth. And when we do histology, all you have is
necrotic tissue left. So p38 seems to be playing a really
important role.
And I have to stop you and sort of warn that
when we realize there's a growth inhibition and there's
apoptosis inhibition, we realize we have
to talk about metabolism. So I'm sorry
to upset anybody. You can leave the room now if you need to,
but we're going to talk about metabolism.
So
this has been really tough for me to learn a whole new field, but I'm trying my
best, and we have this fantastic collaborator, Kelsey Fisher Wellman at Wake
Forest, who can
essentially profile with really great and exquisite
depth with O2K, sort of what the
respiration is in these cells. And what we
see is that
both basal and max respiration are down, but
across a number of substrates, this is true.
So LNCaP are sensitive. Resistant
is an in vivo derived model of enzalutamide resistant.
The same is true for a separate pair of these
cells. These are just
inhibited in their respiration. They seem to be really
quiescent.
And
one
consequence of this quiescence is an
alteration in membrane polarity in the mitochondria.
So this is where things get really interesting for
me.So you can measure this altered
membrane polarity with a simple dye, JC-1.
So in canonically polarized
mitochondria, this dye gets in, it aggregates, and it
fluoresces red. In a depolarized
mitochondria, these JC-1 molecules
exhibit or behave as monomers,
and the dyes can be
detected as a green fluorescence.
So by looking at the red to green ratio, you can understand the
membrane polarity. And in fact, as we would've predicted from their
respirometry,
the drug sensitive cells have quite
canonical and sort of normal polarization, but
the resistant cells really have this loss of
membrane polarity.
And
this is, again, another conserved
mechanism, but what we see is this
change in membrane potential
may be through
the complex five of the electron transport chain.
And complex five,
the role of it, it's just a pump. So on
the left here, canonical use of complex five.
What ends up happening is these protons go through the pump.
The pump runs in what is considered the
forward motion. It uses ATP, it can use this
motion to create ATP from ADP. But
that's a consequence of the pumps moving.
It's not the
need. The need is to maintain a proton gradient.
If cells lose their proton gradient too much, it
triggers apoptosis. And remember that these cells are
resistant to apoptosis. So the pump has
evolved to run in reverse actually,
so it can burn a little ATP and pump
protons back the other way.
And so there's a way to test this. Again, Kelsey gets all the credit
for this. I'm just sort of trying to fumble my way
through explaining it to you, but Kelsey's really suggested this really
great experiment. You can give oligomycin, and oligomycin
should stop this pump from working.
If it's working in the forward direction, you should get
hyperpolarization of the
membrane, and you can measure this with a dye, TMRM.
If you give oligo and the pump is acting in reverse, you
get depolarization,
and that's exactly what happens. These are just controls that we use to kind of
measure and ground truth a little bit.
But you can see with oligo here, hyperpolarization
in the sensitive, depolarization in the resistant.
So these resistant or persistent cells are
actually running this pump in reverse.
And there's a
12 kilodalton little alpha helix.
It's actually a nothing of a protein.
It's called ATPIF1, ATP synthase
inhibitory factor. And its job,
as it were, is to stick in this pump and prevent it
from running in the reverse direction.
You can imagine that there's got to be some evolutionary pressure to not
run this pump sort of back and forth, back and forth in either direction.
So this inhibitory factor sits there and
prevents the pump from going in the reverse direction.
And Shubhjyoti really hypothesized that maybe this
IF1 is reduced, and that's causing some ATP
hydrolysis, and that's exactly what he sees.
And we've seen this now in a fourth model of a completely
different patient cell line, LAPC4.
The resistant cells have a reduction in this ATPIF1.
We also see this in circulating tumor cells
from
RNA-Seq data from patients that are progressing
on an ARPI and in a separate cohort, the Alum call
data from non-responders compared to responders.
So we see the loss of this pump inhibitory
factor in patient data as well. And there's some
connection, and we can't quite figure out what it is yet, but there's some
connection to p38, in which you can give the
p38 inhibitor and you can drive this
inhibitory factor back on.
And this inhibitory factor is also sufficient to induce resistance.
So if we knock down ATPIF1 in sensitive cells, we
can drive resistance to the enzalutamide.
Okay. So we were sort of talking about costs of resistance
before. And
does anybody else feel like AACR has put a bell on
them? I feel like I've been walking around
like... Anyway. So
we sort of started the search for a vulnerability
in how do you target this
reduction in membrane potential?
And it turns out that you can use the targeting moiety
for something like MitoQ, which is an antioxidant.
It's just a cation that goes naturally
homes to the mitochondria and
further depolarizes the membrane.
And the cancer cells in general, but the
resistant cells are exquisitely sensitive to this
otherwise non-toxic cation. Normal cells don't
really care about it. In vivo, the same thing happens.
We start to get a little bit of growth here, and then
these tumors just tank.
Mind you, they're given drug here, so they're growing in the presence of drug.
These are resistant cells. They're kind of ticking along in the presence of drug.
But again, there's no
consequence to the mice, and this is all done in
mice. So we think we have a vulnerability
here.So, oh, I now just now see the
clock. I had zero on the clock this whole time, but here it is.
Okay. I'm doing well,
in case anybody was worried for me.
So
just to sort of summarize the story, which I find
really incredible,
a non-resistant or a
non-persistent cell type really has
this canonical polarization. It's running ATP
synthase in the canonical forward flux direction,
and that is kept in check by ATPIF1.
That's maintained. Under the challenge
of drug, these cells are not growing appreciably.
They're metabolically quiescent.
That, we think, is inducing some stress, which in some
way, which we need to work out the mechanism, is
driving down ATPIF1. Remember, we can give an inhibitor of this and
drive it back up. But that's causing these cells to really just
limp along with a reduced membrane potential that we think we
can target with this non-toxic cation.
Okay. So I think I got at all of that summary, but
really, we believe that therapy mirrors resource depletion in
non-cancer systems, and that that quiescence is just an
evolved system that
pervades all of life, essentially.
And,
we think if we're careful and thoughtful about these studies, we can
really identify vulnerabilities that would prevent that
rediversification. I think
that's the major challenge right now is enabling that
rediversification.
Okay, just a couple of acknowledgments.
Andy Armstrong is my physician partner in all of this and
partner in crime. Shibjyoti did all the work.
But Andy gives
tremendous clinical insight and perspective, and I try to partner
with a physician in all the work that I do for that reason.
Kelsey, I also wanted to highlight because he had some of the great
guidance on this. And if you want to learn more, this is an educational
session. We edited a book, and we have some great contributions
from folks.
And then we have a working group at AACR.
It's fast-growing
and really,
I would say, really engaged and thoughtful and great discussion.
So please feel free to join. And if you want to
check out our special issue on EMPH, please do.
I think that's all I have. So thanks for your attention.
I'll be happy to take questions.
And I'm seeing we're close to time, right?
So,
you can catch me
offline or if we have one question. Yeah, go for it. Yeah.
Yeah. Fantastic talk. I
guess I'm wondering if you looked into
senescence and maybe-
We did
... P38 could be inducing a sort of senescent phenotype.
Yeah. We looked. There's no
SAS that we could detect by like ELISAs and
other methods. They have a little bit higher beta gal,
but I think we're probably not... They're differentiating
and dying as we propagate these cells.
We don't see a lot of that in vivo, so it's
quasi-senescent. I don't know even how we would define that, but
not a strong signal of senescence.
But we
were totally on track with you, for sure. Yeah.
Thank you.
Good question. Thank you. Yeah.
Yeah. Thanks for the great talk.
My question is, are you able to track the dynamics of
the changes of
the ATP synthase inhibitor
expression in maybe earlier passages of the persister cell lines
over time? And then also, are you able
to
assess similar changes in
other non-drug mediated forms of
resistance? So like resistance, for example.
Non-drug mediated forms? Yeah, like-
Radiographic resistance.
Or like hypoxia or some... Yeah.
Exactly.
We haven't done any of that, but we talk about it all the time.
The longitudinal bit is really important because we can't figure out which
came first, the P38 or the quiescence.
I have a clue, though, that if we give just a few days of drug,
like very acute drug, we don't see any P38, but we see
plenty of quiescence. So I think anyway, we're getting
there, but we haven't done that. We need to do it.
And the other one we haven't done, but we're thinking about other drugs first and
not other conditions. But great questions. Yeah, thanks.
Thanks again to the speakers, and thanks for your attention. I appreciate it.
Have a great time.